wins and losses
they say that's the measure of an
athlete the first championship in
franchise history
but we can't separate the athlete from
the humans he's receiving heavy moves
i look at the african-american being the
press in this country and i don't stand
for that most important factor
is respect period black athletes are
celebrated on the court
but feared awful an nba player tased by
police
their talent is worth millions but their
voices deemed worthless
but athletes have always and we'll
always
fight for victory we will definitely not
shut up and dribble
not just in basketball will be a voice
for the voiceless but for the culture
maya moore stepping away from basketball
to fight for justice
so we owe it to the game and to the
people to share the whole story
from court to concrete being an nba
player don't exclude me from no
conversation
because this is bigger than basketball
it has to stop i want real change in
americana taylor the rest of you can't
separate peace
i am somebody